Hey team it’s Charlie, this week for my
bonus video I reached into the mailbag since
I haven’t done a Game of Thrones Q&A in
a couple weeks.
There’s also been a few important things
going on with the show lately so a few of
the questions get into that but I’ll also
have some announcements at the end of the
video.
Now to questions, careful for spoilers for
everything through season 4.
So let’s get going
Question 1 - igo 170 asks do you think World
of Ice and Fire will be out of date when Martin
publishes the rest of the books?
There’s a lot of things that aren’t going
to be in there but the book is mostly intended
to be additive material that the future novels
won’t cover in depth.
It’s not going to get into the life story
for all the characters in the novels.
He’s written a lot of new things for it.
Not full chapters but snippets of history.
The preview he released of Aegon the Conqueror
is a good example.
He’ll have things like that in the book.
It’s not going to be a summary of everything
that’s going on right now.
So yes, there will be a lot of new things
happening after it’s published, but it was
never going to be a complete history of everyone
and everything.
I haven’t seen the table of contents yet,
but think of world of ice and fire as being
like the book of maps they released.
Lands of Ice and Fire combined with some extra
historical information about some of the families
and places.
There are complete family trees for the starks
and the targaryens.
The way they said it made me think they only
did those two families, but without a table
of contents I can’t confirm that.
The book is out tuesday October 28th so I
might give a few copies away that week.
There is a kindle edition but I also pre-ordered
the hardback.
It’s going to be a beautiful book, so if
you were ever going to buy the physical book,
this would be a good time.
Question 2 - Marzie asks why did Daenerys
say that Viserys wasn’t a true dragon.
If fire can’t hurt dragons does that mean
he wasn’t a Targaryen?
That’s actually a misconception.
Targaryens can totally be burned by fire
when magic is not involved.
Wildfire is particularly deadly to them.
Especially when they try to eat it.
It’s one of the things the books and the
show haven’t fully explained, but it gets
into magic.
When Daenerys sits in Khal Drogo’s fire
and emerges unburnt it could have been blood
magic, which sounds a lot like the magic the
Valyrians practiced.
The show also called the burning of the leeches
in season 3 blood magic, so it could also
be related to the magic of the red god.
Or it could be a completely unrelated type
of magic.
I don’t totally expect the books to spell
it out, but that’s where additive books
like World of Ice and Fire come in.
Martin will probably continue to support extra
books like that.
The book itself was pioneered by the people
behind Westeros dot org and Martin just helped
out.
It would be like someone writing a complete
history of the Time War for Doctor Who.
That show will probably never fully do that
event, but it’s this big huge thing that
fans want to know about.
So anytime people complain about Winds of
Winter, just remember how much new info we
get from those extra books.
Question 3 - Navdaz asks Can you do a video
about the unexplored places in the world like
Sothoryos?
There are a couple of really big places the
books haven’t gone yet.
And I say yet, because Martin has talked about
Flashbacks to Old Valyria before the doom
in future books.
Sothoryos however you want to pronounce it,
is a good analog of Africa, just in the way
Daenerys describes it inhabitants and jungles
makes me think of the Amazon or sub saharan
Africa.
Characters in the books have been there but
I don’t think there’s quite enough information
about that continent in particular to do a
whole video on.
It’s way too big a mystery for Martin to
not go there in a future book.
Winter is supposedly coming for everyone right?
So Winter would have to come to the Jungle
too.
Until the books go there I’ll probably just
work those places into other videos when it’s
relevant.
Question 4 - This Vik asks are the faith militant
a defence force or do they also attack certain
houses?
Their standing mission is to uphold the orders
of the High Septon.
Or in the case of Season 5 the High Sparrow
if you want to use his nickname.
In the past they’ve only gone after people
they think are violating morals of the faith.
They’re like the censorship police.
If you are doing something that they deem
unholy or ungodly they will meet you with
force and bring you before the High Septon
for judgement.
Because we might see them in season 5, if
you have read the books please use spoiler
tags in the comments.
Question 5 - Man I Hate wasp asks whos stories
are split in books four and five?
The books were split because Martin felt he
couldn’t fit all the POV characters into
one book.
So the time period is the same for both books,
you just don’t hear from book 4 characters
in book 5 unless the characters in book 5
are thinking about book 4 characters.
The POV characters are a mixture of new characters
they just cast in season 5 like Hotah and
characters they cut out like Arys Oakheart
and Arianne Martell.
Most of what happens in Book 4 will be season
5 of the show.
But because Daenerys and Tyrion don’t really
appear in Book 4, season 5 will also get into
Book 5 stuff.
Question 6 - Flame for Moonlight asks will
there be more Dragons in season 5?
Yes, lots more dragons.
I feel like of all the possible CG things
the show could choose to do, the dragons are
one of the first things they think about every
year.
I feel like the producers and casual fans
of the show use dragons as a way to explain
what it’s about to other people.
Like when someone who has never read the books
asks what’s game of thrones about?
Another random person says Dragons and Ice
People.
That’s a fraction of it, but it’s something
easy for non-hardcore people to latch on to.
So there will always be dragons on the show.
They’d be the last thing that would ever
get cut.
Question 7 - Albert A asks, do you think they’d
ever freeze someone’s story from the books
for a whole season?
Not one of the big main characters.
Little characters like Gendry, Hodor and Lancel
yes, either they’d just not use them for
a season or they’d just drop them from the
story completely.
Hodor is confirmed sitting out season 5 even
though Isaac Hemstead Wright has said he has
shot scenes for
the premiere.
When Martin talks about the show changing
more and more from the books over time, it’s
because the show keeps using characters that
Martin hasn’t used
and as a result it doesn’t have room to
bring in new characters that Martin brings
in.
Like Arianne Martell.
Question 8 - Troll Kidd asks would HBO ever
fire one of the stars like Emilia Clarke if
they said a spoiler?
Not if they felt they were critical to the
ending they’d envisioned.
And to be honest, I feel like all the hardcore
fans will have already imagined every possible
outcome for the show.
Most of the people that watch the show don’t
search for extra information online, that’s
usually just the highly engaged part of the
fandom that really wants to talk about what’s
going on.
Most people are just passive observers.
Like they want HBO to wheel the dump truck
of content up to their house and leave.
That’s slowly changing because of something
google calls generation C. It’s a way to
describe the millenial, gen x, gen y crowd
that consume content primarily on digital
platforms.
Those people, of which we are all a part are
much more likely to actively engage with shows,
search for information about it online and
engage in online conversations about in on
social media
like this youtube video.
In the next 5 years, we will become the majority.
But we’re not quite there yet.
Question 9 - Dan Cummings asks, could you
do a video on what scenes they have been filming?
Okay, since this could be potentially super
spoilery I’m going to put this tag up and
you can just skip till it goes away if you
want.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
They just started building the Winterfell
set again, so there will be lots of Winterfell
scenes.
Remember, the Boltons were marching there
during season 4.
They also constructed sets for the House of
Black and White, the place where the faceless
men are headquartered.
They filmed near the cathedral in Dubrovnik
with Cersei, so they’re doing that big scene
from Book 4.
They filmed a river boat scene with Tyrion,
Varys and possibly Jorah Mormont.
Mormont was described in the same post I saw
but he wasn’t pictured with Tyrion and Varys.
And none of them were actually filmed.
It was just reported they were on set.
And they’ve also filmed the fighting pits
of Meereen.
This is what it looks like.
Most of those scenes are for pretty major
things, so again, please use spoiler tags
if you want to talk more about them in the
comments.
Okay spoilers over Question 10 - Juan Hunter
asks, how many seasons do you think the show
will run and will they do prequel shows?
HBO seems pretty comfortable with 7 seasons
for less successful things like True Blood,
so bare minimum 7.
Game Of Thrones is by far their most popular
Drama since Sopranos, so they’ll try to
keep it going as long as the producers can
keep coming up with new stories.
I think it will be season 6 before we see
how much they stretch the plot of the books
out.
There’s no reason they couldn’t do 10
seasons, but I’m not expecting them to take
it that far.
As for prequels.
George RR Martin signed a development deal
during season 1 for a separate show.
There’s no word on what that will be other
than it will be a prequel and it will not
be from recent history.
It’s not going to be a Robert’s Rebellion
prequel.
It would more likely be from the time of the
Dance of The Dragons or during the reign of
one of the crazier Targaryen Kings.
Either way whenever it gets here I’ll continue
to support it.
But thank you so much for submitting questions
everyone.
I’ll try to post my next bonus video either
this friday or next friday.
I’m trying to turn Fridays into my Game
of Thrones days but so many new things are
coming I’ll just have to see how it goes.
Congrats to this week’s giveaway winner
Meli West.
You get your choice of any of Martin’s books.
I’ll reach out to you on your channel for
details.
So check your inbox.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I’m doing weekly bonus videos in the
off season, if you also like talking about
game of thrones please subscribe to join the
team.
I also do a weekly book giveaway as you’ve
seen.
Couple of extra announcements.
Since I’m having enough trouble getting
regular bonus videos out with all the other
new tv shows coming I’m going to postpone
live rewatches till the holidays this year.
Just so things don’t get too crazy.
This week Gotham and Agents of SHIELD start.
I’ve done preview videos for both shows
so I’ll add links in the description.
You should check them out they’ll be a lot
of fun.
Gotham is tonight and Agents of SHEILD is
tuesday night.
UK people might have to wait a couple weeks
if you don’t stream your shows.
Right now click here to learn about the Religions
on Game of Thrones and Click here to learn
about the Faceless Men.
Thanks for watching, now everybody high five
and we'll meet back up for Gotham later tonight.